ziehen wir jetzt direkt weiter zu dem
thema von marc friedrich genau und zwar
mein thema ist die inflation wir alle
werden enteignet durch die inflation
diese war zuletzt fast 5% und wir spüren
es jeden tag eigentlich bestimmt beim
einkaufen beim heizen beim tanken aber
auch immer die stromrechnungen sehen und
dabei sagte die ezb noch vor wenigen
monaten das ist nur temporär wäre und
gesehen es ist nicht temporär ganz im
gegenteil die inflation ist da und wird
auch bleiben das musste die ezb auch
kleinlaut zugeben und man zieht auch
dass die inflation auch sich
beschleunigt für 2022 wird 4% anvisieren
vier prozent inflation bedeutet aber
dass die vier prozent kaufkraft pro jahr
verlieren das bedeutet überhaupt in der
zeit von 18 jahren bei vier prozent
würde man die hälfte seiner kaufkraft
verlieren würde dahinschmelzen also fakt
ist die ezb politik hat versagt treibt
die schere zwischen arm und reich immer
weiter auseinander sorgt für sozialen
sprengstoff wird die altersarmut weiter
befeuern wir sehen nicht nur ein
versagen der notenbankpolitik sondern
auf dem politik durch eine falsche
energie wende die wir gesehen haben und
dahingehend müssen wir einschreiten und
dahingehend muss jeder auch gucken wie
er sein geld in sicherheit bringt vor
der inflation vor dem kaufkraft
gestohlen das ist mein stichwort ja weil
ich habe ihr buch also so steg gelesen
ganz schnell noch einmal durchgeblättert
und ich bin total deprimiert ihr buch
hat mich so traurig gemacht denn ich
habe ja
bank kann überhaupt nicht trauen ihr
aber schließlich warten auch nicht dann
habe ich immer gedacht also betonen
wollen ich war immer für häuser kaufen
ja gottes willen das mit der dann
besteuert schwer besteuert weil irgendwo
müssen die dann wieder das geld her
holen von mir wahrscheinlich ich
überhaupt nicht ich muss heimlich
gold.com von habe ich nämlich ein
säugling heimliche gold caro für jene
jeden tag unter 2000 euro
kaufe ich dann an dieser säule
und aber wo vergraben ich das ja
wenn sich das rumspricht ja dann habe
ich viele besucher und vor allem wenn
ich jeden tag da hingehe ich brauche man
muss ja dann oft hingehen wenn man
einige das sollten wir doch mal ein
gespartes geld umsetzen will wenn man
ein brot kaufen in der bäckerei muss man
so ein goldbarren mit einem
verein wo verstecke ich das zu hause
dann habe ich auch noch nicht mal
nachgehen und alles was mir einfällt
wird auch dem dieb ein und vom im
tiefkühlfach
waschen der wäsche auch nicht ja
keksdose nicht und vor allem vergesse
ich es womöglich ja wo es ist das ist
das eine dann entnehme ich ihrem buch
das bitcoins also das sicher sind
bislang habe ich mich damit überhaupt
nicht beschäftigt ja aber sie sagen ja
das ist die einzige möglichkeit
wert zu schaffen dann wo die beine nicht
ran können einer von einem zählen also
geld also gold diamanten hole
ex-kollege haben ja gerade nicht mehr
einkaufen im markt gibt es kein gestern
schon mal weißt du alle gerne wenn man
sie gar nicht aber ich heute noch ein
thema kurz erwähnen ergänzt es ist ultra
spannend es ist eine historische zweiten
aber fakt ist eigentlich müsste die ezb
ja um die inflation zu stoppen die
zinsen erhöhen kann sie aber nicht weil
dann würden die zombie unternehmen in
europa pleitegehen ab auch die zombie
länder weil wir sehen ja in frankreich
spanien portugal griechenland sind de
facto alle pleite das heißt wenn die ezb
die zinsen markant erhöhen würde hätten
die an ein kleines büro wird teurer ja
ja die deutsche die europäischen exporte
würden teurer ja das würde die
realwirtschaft wieder merkt genau aber
es gibt einen aspekt dabei über den wir
uns gar nicht mein verhalten haben den
letzten jahren das sind nämlich die
lohnforderungen die jetzt kommen wenn
die inflation 45 prozent begonnen weil
auch die gewerkschaften mindestens so
viele fragen am ende mindestens so viel
haben wollen was wiederum die inflation
mindest neuer rechter hält oder sogar an
weil die erste frage die einmal hier ein
feldherr friedrich ist ja
selbstverständlich die ist es jetzt
vielleicht auch panikmache kann es sich
nicht vielleicht auch einfach wieder
stabilisieren selbst die ezb sagt er
jetzt wir werden uns auf ein hohes
niveau einpendeln wer also wird es 1 4
prozent bei den für 2022 prognostiziert
und man darf nicht vergessen die wahre
inflation ist noch viel hören wird durch
meine tante wir haben in den haag
rechnen die aber in der stabilisierung
bis 2023 der die haben sich aber bis
jetzt immer verschätzt man doch mal
ehrlich
es hat schon geheißen wir werden kann
inflation sehen pustekuchen die
inflation ist da und ist ganz schön
saftig und in den nächsten jahren sehe
ich auf jeden fall weitere hohe
inflationsraten und 34 dann werden die
löhne vielleicht steigen aber das
befeuert dann die ganze insel und
spirale unter dem strich von die
menschen trotzdem also altersarmut droht
ja auch weil die meisten deutschen haben
ja keinen keinen kann kein besitzer also
wenn das geld auf dem konto liegt haben
wir negative stellt wir haben den
negativ negativ sind dabei der schon
seit 2010 enteignet und die ezb wird
weiter geld drucken und wenn die
geldmenge steigt steigt auch die
interessieren sind mit option ist aber
noch verraten was tut man denn gegen die
inflation wenn die ezb den banken ja
wenn die neben frau riekel im garten
umher
aber solange die notenbanken weltweit
unlimitiert geld drucken muss man
einfach genau das gegenteil machen in
limitierte werte investieren also alles
wird im preis steigen weil es bedeutet
lediglich dass die kaufkraft von meinem
geld immer weniger dann also immobilien
werden wie der inflation aber was muss
der staat tun um die inflation
einzudämmen ja ich kann ganz klar sagen
der staat wird gar nichts tun weil der
staat ist der profiteur der inflation
weil er kann sich auf kosten der bürger
in schulden weil er negativzinsen
bekommt auf seine stabile banken tun
auch nix also im ganzen ausgelieferte
system muss erst gegen die wand fahren
wir brauchen an der stelle wird
sozusagen interessant denn politisch und
so dass man merkt wie eine zusage sich
die fußnägel auf wurde denn natürlich
müsste eine sozialdemokratisch geführte
bundesregierung was dagegen tun und
natürlich ist es unanständig und
widerlich dass sich das anzuhören dass
ausgerechnet eine geo die von der
arbeiterpartei habe ich doch richtig
sind das noch warten sie mal okay der
früheren aber dafür geführt wird mit
einem mann wie olaf scholz an der spitze
der viele jahre finanzminister
da müsste doch jetzt sozusagen einen 1
gegen katalogs alles andere ist ja
wenigstens bigott wenn nicht sogar
unanständig und da muss ich sagen für
mich schon ein klares signal des
kanzlers dass er sich des themas annimmt
und auch die menschen sozusagen mit dem
mit der mit der gewissheit ausstattet
das unter seiner regie seiner
regierungszeit es nicht noch quasi
eskaliert also eigentlich meine ich will
jetzt nicht sozusagen ist klar dass wenn
man mehr geld hat macht man sich auch
sorgen und so weiter aber die meisten
leute haben ja keine golden diese sieben
garten
getrieben hat das und die haben das
recht dass insbesondere diese regierung
die eigentlich jede aber insbesondere
diese regierung jetzt antworten was
sagen da gibt es ja einen ganz
interessanten effekt in dieser regierung
die neue arbeiterpartei könnte man
manchmal glauben ist die fdp das war sie
niemals also christian lindner als
finanzminister hat jetzt mehrfach gesagt
wir werden er wird was tun gegen die
steigenden energiepreise er wird die
pendlerpauschale erhöhen er wird darüber
nachdenken wir auf andere weise den
armen häuser würden jetzt von den armen
helfen werden das ist ja völlig neue
töne aus der fdp hat sie früher nie
gesagt wird auch nicht gelobt dafür weil
viele trauen dem frieden nicht aber es
ist so
ja ja
ist denn so geht er zum thema machen es
sich die lösung ist das grundübel nicht
lösen eigentlich müssten tatsächlich die
sozialisten und die spd jeden tag vor
der ezb demonstrieren weil es genau
denen ihren
wenig weiß mache aber aber fakt ist
tatsächlich nein die machen gar nichts
und wir müssten eigentlich das
geldsystem komplett neue reformieren
dann gibt's natürlich entwicklungen wie
zum beispiel bitcoin aber fakt ist wir
verlieren unseren wohlstand deutschland
ist in gefahr und das ist sozialer
sprengstoff war die show aber jetzt
haben
wird doch warum eigentlich
wird
erklärt
beschreiben das alles
können sie sich vorstellen dass
ein kleines sparten hat jetzt in reihen
den bitkom
dann ist es aber fakt ist ja jeder wird
jetzt momentan enteigneten
lebensversicherung hat geld auf dem
konto oder ob man einfach nur ein
bisschen geld unterm kopfkissen hat als
der deutsche muss was machen und da
kommt ein riesen problem auf uns zu was
mir große sorge macht wald sozialer
sprengstoff ist er weist vor allem die
ärmsten trifft diejenigen die jetzt
gerade jetzt schon kämpfen müssen jetzt
heitz rechnung zahlen der steigt der
gaspreis ums dreifache und wie sollen
den adäquat für alterversorgung
altersarmut wird ein riesen thema werden
und die politik ist nicht nur
feuerwehrmann auf der anderen seite
sondern sie sind auch der
brandbeschleuniger war ich kann jetzt
schon voraussagen dass die spd
wenn die die jetzt sozusagen in der
situation sind alt sind wird die spd
hoffentlich nicht mehr regieren und dann
ist sie wieder da und dann wird sich
sagen das war eine schädliche politik
gehört und dann muss man sie daran
erinnern du musst dann schreiben klar
aber es war
ja genau was mich beunruhigt sie
prophezeien einen crash sie sagen das
ist das einzige was als einzige
zukunftsperspektive dass alles
zusammenbricht und dann wird eine neue
gesellschaft der mensch sendung immer
durch schalter oder also das ist ja auch
eine bio kann was bedeutet dieser crash
ja wahrscheinlich wieder neues geld
system endlich bereits zu umarmen wir
sehen doch seit zehn jahren zu einem
dauer krisen modus den notenbanken
drucken weltweit geld zu viel wie noch
nie die schulden steigen da es ja die da
es aber dadurch die inflation nicht
gestiegen bisher die steigt jetzt und
zwar wegen anderer effekte nicht wegen
der politik ledigen der nun erwägen den
user kennen und ich ahne schon
irgendwann werden sie
präsidentschaftskandidat einer partei
weil alle die in crash vorausgesagt
haben später so karriere gemacht
werden wird sich gar nicht der stadt und
natürlich jetzt beispielsweise die
karriere von von herr otte ist ja gerade
er so ein bisschen auf dem
höhepunkt jetzt aber aber weitere
schritte aber fragt nicht doch als im
bestehenden system gibt es ja
anscheinend keine lösung was er 2016
druckt die ezb geld sie hat den zins auf
dem historischen tief und enteignet
damit nicht ganz europa die ganze
bevölkerung hin dass es immer fragen
gern wäre jetzt zwei möglichkeiten haben
sagen wir mal wir haben die mag oder
bitcoin was wenn dann besser welches
system meiner ansicht nach auf jeden
fall ein limitiertes gut was limitiertes
durch einen mathematischen code und es
ist eben nicht er geld was einfach auf
knopfdruck produziert wenn du wirst
nicht wie viel die ezb wirklich
produziert die bilanz hat grad 8,6
millionen euro eher auf der hohen kante
rissen ungefähr 100 8 82 prozent vom
europäischen bip also ich würde den
limitierten wert der auf mathematik
bewohner bitcoin ist nicht stabil
lediglich ob sie jetzt seine bahn
hinunter und dann ist vieles weg dass
wenn wir die auf fragen da müssen wir
auch mal eine sendung machen also er ist
volatil das gebe ich zu aber auch nach
oben müssen jetzt bei über 40.000 dollar
und hat angefangen bei wenigen cent aber
es ist ja nur ein teil der betrachtung
nächste geldsystem 1 nach digital sein
es wird mit digitalen euro
wahrscheinlich geben aber wir müssen uns
klar wir müssen endlich mal über ein
geldsystem sprechen was nachhaltig ist
was den menschen dient und nicht nur
einigen wenigen weil profitiert in den
krisen haben immer die reichen immer
noch alle gewählten systeme gibt es
überhaupt nicht alle nur von
beschränkter dauer also ja du bist aber
genauso wie
wir müssen uns jetzt etwas einfallen und
ich hab mir vorschlagen es sind die
steigenden benzinpreise wurscht ich
denke sowieso immer nur für 30 euro
auch eine lösung
und so an die politik wird